The life of an actor seems so glamorous from
the outside.
Fame, money, and fans are all part of the
gig.
When we become so used to seeing these people
on the big screen, it’s easy to forget that
they’re real people too.
And when real people need to blow off some
steam, everyone has a favorite method.
But these stars have found solace in some
particularly interesting places.
Here are 10 Famous Actors With Weird Hobbies/Obsessions.
Johnny Depp, Dolls
Johnny Depp has played a ton of different
characters over the course of his career.
And has the ability to completely transform
himself with every one.
What’s his secret?
Character development.
And as a part of his process, Depp occasionally
uses props to assist with the method: Barbies.
The actor has an insane doll collection, including
many rare Barbies.
But he’s not going to keep them in the box,
oh no.
Depp has been quoted as saying that he uses
playtime to workshop new voices for his upcoming
characters.
We’ve heard of method acting before, but
he does it differently.
And given that it’s Johnny Depp we’re
talking about, that’s exactly what we would
expect.
Nicolas Cage, Spending money
If you won the lottery, what would you spend
the money on?
This idea is something that most of us can
only dream about.
But for Nicolas Cage, those dollar signs are
very real.
No, he didn’t technically win the lottery,
but his spending habits indicate otherwise.
It seems the actor just loves shelling out
the Benjamins.
Where the average person fantasizes about
going on a vacation or paying off their debts,
Cage would rather spend that dough on albino
king cobras, shrunken heads, and haunted mansions.
That’s an unorthodox collection, but when
you consider who it belongs to, it kinda makes
sense.
Gwyneth Paltrow, Spanish/Goop
With every new season, Gwyneth Paltrow has
a new obsession and one hell of a soapbox
to shout them from: her blog!
Paltrow’s high-horse is named Goop, and
thanks to the actress’ obsession with Spanish,
now she can be condescending in two languages!
Paltrow’s impossible recommendations have
come under fire for being expensive, unnecessarily
complicated, and downright unsustainable.
But if you don’t care about any of that,
then fear not, Spanish speakers!
Because if you’d like to read about $90
face wash or the latest in bronze Japanese
tea-scoop technology, Paltrow has your back.
And is now offering a version of Goop written
in Spanish.
How worldly.
Will Smith, Fencing
At this point, we’re pretty much convinced
that Will Smith can do anything.
An actor, rapper, and producer, Smith has
been an entertainment heavyweight for decades.
As you can probably imagine, that kind of
lifestyle would take it’s toll on the best
of us.
And as Smith has gotten older, he’s joked
about finding low-impact hobbies to keep himself
in tip-top shape, mentally and physically.
So when old pal Tom Cruise introduced him
to fencing, he was all over it.
Apparently the duo would get-together and
practice their skills with David Beckham too.
When you step back and think about it, a movie
starring them as the Three Musketeers might
actually be kind of awesome.
Daniel Radcliffe, Gymnastics
As a child, Daniel Radcliffe got a crash course
in fame.
His work on the Harry Potter movies made him
a household name overnight, and is a title
he carries with him to this day.
Being a part of the wizarding world came with
a lot of challenges for the young actor, including
coordination.
Radcliffe lives with a condition called Dyspraxia
which affects his motor skills.
Since there were some physically demanding
scenes, the actor received gymnastics training.
And after much practice, he found that he
was better able to coordinate his movements
and get through the stunts.
Good thing, too.
Since we can’t imagine anyone more suited
to the role than Radcliffe himself.
Angelina Jolie, Daggers
Angelina Jolie is famous for living a life
off the beaten path.
Wether it’s wearing a vial of her partner’s
blood, or kissing her brother a little too
hard in public, the actress has a bit of a
dark side.
Jolie has said that she’s been building
a collection of knives and daggers ever since
she was a kid.
And when her son Maddox began to show an interest
in Mom’s assortment, she encouraged him
to start a collection of his own.
Throughout it all though, the main undercurrent
in her teachings seems to be about having
respect for the instrument.
Which, when you think about it, isn’t that
different from any other collection.
Tom Hanks, Typewriters
In the ever-evolving world of technology,
it seems like there’s a new device promising
to change your life everyday.
And as a result, there’s a niche of people
raging against the machine.
But for Tom Hanks, his love for the good old-fashioned
typewriter began burning in the late seventies.
The actor has over fifty of them, and even
wrote an essay for the New York Times about
all the reasons why.
Hanks even developed a typewriting app, complete
with different model-specific sound effects.
No matter how good the technology gets, sometimes
going old-school just more satisfying.
Mila Kunis, Star Trek/World of Warcraft
When you think of a stereotypical World of
Warcraft or Star Trek fan, you might picture
a hunchbacked, Mountain Dew-guzzling, Dorito-fingered
outcast.
And sure, there might be some of that.
But guess what?
Nerds can be hot too!
Take Mila Kunis, for example.
The actress has been in the public eye since
That 70’s Show.
But in her private time, she’s a huge fan
of Sci-Fi and identifies herself as a Trekkie.
Apparently Kunis was also so into World of
Warcraft that she had to quit playing for
hours a day in order to maintain her career.
Now that’s dedication.
Liam Neeson, Fly fishing
Let’s play a game.
What kind of activities do you think Liam
Neeson enjoys in his spare time?
Karate?
Shooting guns?
Tracking down lost teens?
If you guessed fly fishing, congratulations!
Your prize is in the mail.
For a man who makes his living kicking ass
and taking names, a calm, easy-going activity
like fishing might seem like a weird choice.
But it actually makes a lot of sense.
Nobody can kick ass 100% of the time, even
if they’re really good at it.
And a quiet retreat to the water can be a
nice change when you spend your days snapping
bad guys’ necks.
Leslie Mann, Unicycling
Leslie Mann is one of the most hilarious ladies
working in Hollywood today.
She’s been in some of the funniest movies
of the last 15 years.
From Knocked Up to The 40-Year Old Virgin,
Mann has perfected her own little breed of
comedy.
It turns out that she’s also pretty coordinated
too!
The actress is a big fan of the unicycle,
and is one of the few people who can actually
ride one.
Riding a bike with two wheels can be challenging
enough, and when you’re left with just a
single wheel, it only gets harder.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any other famous actors with weird
hobbies or obsessions?
Head over to the comments section to tell
us about them.
And be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
for more videos like this one.